as we discussed in the prior video every
programming language has some set of
data types built into the language in
this set usually includes numbers
strings boolean's and perhaps a few
other basic types on top of these
built-in types the programmer can
themselves define additional data types
as they require confusingly these are
often called a user-defined data types
the user here being the programmer the
user of the language the most common
kind of user-defined types are formally
called product types but informally are
called structs short for structures or
classes depending upon the language a
product type aggregates data elements
called fields which each have a name and
a type for example we can define a
product type we'll call person which
let's say is made up of three fields a
string called name a number called age
and a number called weight the order of
the fields by the way is not significant
having defined this person type we can
then create person values each of which
will have its own name age and weight we
call this a product type because the set
of all its possible values is the
product the combination of all possible
values of its fields such types are very
useful because we commonly want to
aggregate multiple pieces of disparate
data into a single coherent unit in this
example whatever information we want to
store about each person in our program
we include that information as fields of
our person type what's formerly known as
a sum type is informally known depending
on the language as a union and enum
short for enumeration or an ADT an
algebraic data type a union is defined
as a set of types and enum is defined as
a set of discrete values and algebraic
data types found in languages like
Haskell can be composed of types like a
union but also discrete values like an
enum this example union here called cat
is a sum of two other types tiger and
Panther and so the set of possible cat
values is all the tiger values plus all
the Panther values for an enum the set
of values are discrete values rather
than types this example enum called
friends has three discrete values Monika
Phoebe and Ross
commonly enum values are represented as
unique integers or as strengths but it
doesn't necessarily matter how these
values are represented all that really
matters is that they can be
distinguished from each other so if
Monica Phoebe and Ross are represented
as integers they must be represented by
different integers for example say 0 1 &
2
perhaps the most important design choice
of a programming language is whether it
should be statically typed in a
statically typed language when you
create a variable you must decide what
types of values it will store and label
it as such
likewise you must decide what types of
inputs and output each function should
have having specified these types the
compiler will then enforce these
constraints for example if you declare a
variable to have type string then
assigning anything other than a string
to the variable will trigger a
compilation error likewise if you
declare a function to take as input a
string and a number then calling that
function with any arguments other than a
string and then a number will trigger a
compilation error the built-in
operations are also checked at compile
time for valid inputs for example a
division operation with inputs that are
not both numbers will also trigger a
compilation error programming languages
that aren't statically typed are said to
be dynamically typed in a dynamically
typed language we don't specify the
types of things and so the compiler
cannot check for improper values and
operations assignments or function calls
only at runtime when operations are
executed does the language check the
types of the inputs for example a
division operation with inputs that are
not both numbers will trigger a runtime
error that aborts the program performing
these operation type checks at runtime
not only incurs extra runtime
performance costs it means that our
simple mistakes are not comp by the
language until they actually happen when
the code runs in a statically typed
language if our code successfully
compiles we know our code is free of
type mistakes and when we do have such
mistakes the compiler tells us exactly
what the mistakes are and on which lines
of code this is why many programmers
prefer statically typed languages on the
other hand some programmers argue that
dynamically typed languages are less
verbose and more flexible among the most
popular languages in use today
statically typed language
seem to be somewhat more commonly used
but we have no really reliable
statistics and usage varies greatly
among different domains of programming
another split between languages is
whether they are weakly typed or
strongly typed the precise meaning of
these terms is not universally agreed
upon but broadly speaking strongly typed
languages impose restrictions that make
certain errors impossible in a memory
safe language for example arbitrary
access of memory is disallowed and this
restriction prevents a whole category of
bugs stemming from accessing the wrong
parts of memory strong typing also
generally implies that the language
makes invalid operations and invalid
function calls impossible static
languages check for such errors during
compilation but most dynamically typed
languages will check for these errors at
runtime and so can be considered
strongly typed in this regard lastly
strongly typed languages tend to be
stricter about conversions between data
types requiring you to make the
conversions explicit this can feel more
verbose and less convenient but it helps
prevent errors a method is basically a
function that belongs to a particular
datatype the method has a special
parameter usually called this which is
of the same type as the data type to
which the method belongs so say for
example we have a class cat and we give
cat a method named meow which takes a
number as input the method actually also
takes as input a cat but that is left
implicit to call this method the syntax
is a little odd the regular arguments
here a single number are put inside the
parentheses like normal but the cat
value is placed before the name of the
method separated by a dot so what's the
point
well one small stylistic nicety of
methods compared to regular functions is
that different types can have methods of
the same name like say the class's cat
and dog could both have their own method
named sleep sleep of cat and sleep of
dog would be several methods that just
happen to have the same name when we
call a method the language determines
which method to call based not just on
the name but also the type of the
special argument before the dot the more
significant rationale for methods though
relates to subtype relationships so what
are some typos lationship s-- well if a
date
type B is a sub type of data type a then
values of type B are considered to also
be values of type a this means then that
anywhere in code a value of type a is
expected a value of type B is valid as
well in dynamically typed languages the
concept of subtypes is kept informal if
B is a subtype of a then B should have
all the same fields and methods as a but
a dynamically typed language does not
enforce this in statically typed
languages however subtype relationships
are formally declared in code and
enforced by the compiler so say for a
variable of type a we can assign it
values of type a of course but we can
also assign it values of type B if B is
declared to be a subtype of a so how do
we create subtype relationships in a
statically typed language well there are
two kinds of subtype relationships
inheritance and interface implementation
if we create a class dog which inherits
from another class animal dog then
implicitly has all of the fields and
methods of animal in addition to any
fields and methods we define and dog
itself we are effectively saying that
dogs are a specific kind of animal and
so it should have everything that makes
up an animal but then also have more
stuff specific to dogs if then we create
a variable X of type animal we can
assign a dog value tax because a dog is
a kind of animal assuming animal has a
method eat we can call this method on X
and the dog value stored in X will be
passed into the call however assuming
dog has a method bark that it doesn't
inherit from animal we cannot call bark
on X because the compiler knows X to be
an animal not specifically a dog we may
happen to know in this case that X is
currently storing a dog but the compiler
only knows that it stores some animal in
cases where X stores something other
than the dog calling dogs bark method
would be invalid and so the compiler
won't allow it
even though the call would be valid in
this particular case as a rule the
compiler never presumes to know the
value of anything because in most cases
it can't know in this case the compiler
could figure out that X at this point
will always store dog but for
consistency it doesn't bother
identifying these trivial cases
when a class inherits a method it can
choose to override it meaning it can
provide its own definition of the method
here dog is over right in the eat method
which it inherits from animal now when
we assign a dog to animal variable X and
call eat on X the compiler knows the
call is valid just like before but it
still doesn't know whether X currently
stores an animal or a dog and so it
can't decide which eat method to Col
that choice is deferred to when the call
is actually executed at runtime and in
this case because X will store a dog
when the call is made it's the method of
dog that will be called if next we store
an animal in X a subsequent call to eat
calls the eat method of animal itself so
the rule is which version of the method
gets called depends upon the type of the
value at the time of the call aside from
inheritance we can also create subtype
relationships with interface
implementation an interface is
considered a data type but strangely
interfaces have no data themselves
instead an interface is a set of what we
call method signatures a method
signature specifies the name parameter
types and return type of a method but
has no actual code here we have an
interface sea creature which has three
method signatures the first named swim
has no parameters and returns nothing
the second named eat has a parameter of
type food and returns a number the third
name sleep has a parameter of type time
and returns nothing but itself an
interface isn't useful because we can't
create values of the interface type
itself however a class that has methods
matching all of the interfaces
signatures is allowed to declare that it
implements the interface making the
class a subtype of the interface if say
then we have a variable X of type sea
creature and dolphin is a class that
implements sea creature then we can
assign a dolphin value to X we can then
call methods of the interface on X they
call to swim here invokes the swim
method of dolphin passing the dolphin
value as a special argument once again
the compiler doesn't ever presume to
know what actual value is stored in any
variable so it won't let us call the
dolphin method squeak uh necks because
squeak is not part of the sea creature
interface in this case yes the call
we'll be valid because X stores a
dolphin but again the compiler never
presumes to know that and in other cases
X might store some other kind of sea
creature that doesn't have such a method
so the compiler can't allow the call if
though we assign another kind of sea
creature to X say a whale then calling
swim on X invokes a swim method of whale
like with overridden methods and
inheritance the determination of which
version of the method to call happens
when the call actually executes
understand that interfaces are generally
not formalized in dynamically typed
languages with dynamic typing any
variable can store anything and so the
compiler can't check whether method
calls are valid at runtime in these
languages calling a method only triggers
an error if a type has no such method if
we're using a dynamic language the call
to squeak here is valid because when the
call is made X will store a dolphin
which does have such a method
likewise with our inheritance example if
we're using a dynamically typed language
the call to bark here succeeds because
at the time x stores a dog which does
have such a method so let me reiterate
why subtypes are useful say we have some
function foo that takes an animal as
input and returns a sea creature
thanks to subtypes we're not limited to
taking in just one specific type and
returning just one specific type even in
a statically typed language this
function operates on all kinds of
animals and they can return different
kinds of sea creatures in different
branches of its code collections and
statically typed languages also greatly
benefit from subtypes say for example we
want an array that can store both cats
and dogs well in a dynamically typed
language we can just put any values we
want into the slots of any array but in
a statically typed language we have to
specify with the array stores without
subtypes we'd have to choose whether an
array stores only caps or only dogs but
with subtypes we can choose a type of
which both cat and dog are subtypes
allowing us to store both cats and dogs
in the same array assuming here that cat
and dog are subtypes of animal our
animal array can store both cats and
dogs in a
we type language having stored say a dog
in an animal variable what if we want to
access the value as a dog so we can
access the fields and methods that dog
has but animal does not well this
requires what's called a downcast
operation here the compiler only knows X
to be an animal but we know in this case
that X store is a dog the downcast
operation denoted by the target type in
parentheses gets us the value as a dog
rather than an animal be clear the value
is not being transformed in any way
rather the downcast simply performs a
check at runtime to verify the de value
stored in X at this moment is actually a
dog the check trigger is a runtime error
if it fails but otherwise execution
continues as normal and the compiler
considers the value returned by the
downcast to be of type dog which is why
it allows us to assign it to a dog
variable by requiring this check the
compiler is putting responsibility on us
that the value stored in X at this
moment is actually a dog the compiler
just has to trust us but the language
verifies at one time in a statically
typed language having made our code
general-purpose using sub types we
sometimes want to constrain the code to
more specific types by doing so the
compiler in some cases can help us avoid
dumb type errors and also spare us from
cluttering our code with down casts
enter what are usually called generics a
generic function or method uses one or
more type parameters as stand-ins for
one or more types in its code we then
specify actual types to plug in for
these type parameters in each call to
the function or method in this example
we have a function foo with a single
type parameter named T and the function
takes at T as input and returns a T the
parameter T is defined as an animal so
in the code of the function everywhere T
is used it's basically the same as if we
just used animal itself with the type
parameter however when calling the
function we specify an actual type for T
which can be any kind of animal when we
plug in dog for T the function returns a
dog not an animal and so note that we
don't have to downcast when we assign to
the dog variable D when we plug in cat
for T the function returns a cat and so
we can assign the results a cat variable
C the last call here expects a dog so we
can't pass in a cap we can also make our
types generic with type parameters here
the class pet owner uses a single type
parameter named T which is defined as an
animal the class has a field named pet
of type T again be clear that the field
actually just stores an animal but for
particular values of pet owner we
specify a subtype of animal to plug in
for T and then for that particular value
the compiler constraints T to that
subtype if say we create a variable of
type pet owner specialized for cat then
the pet field can only be signed a cat
not a dog or any other subtype of animal
generics may not seem especially
valuable in small examples but in the
context of large programs they give us
greater confidence in the type
correctness of our code while also
sparing us some extra verbosity from
down castes note also that the term of
generic is a bit misleading generics do
not allow us to make our code more
general-purpose subtypes already
accomplished that instead generics
helped us leverage the compiler in a
statically typed language to better
enforce type safety if a value is only
supposed to contain only certain
subtypes we don't want to accidentally
give it the wrong subtypes with generics
the compiler can catch when we make such
mistakes
you